[Musique]
c'est un véritable coup de tonnerre qui
a frappé la france hier soir suite aux
annonces d'olivier ferrand le ministre
de la santé
même si on sait que depuis quelques
jours la situation sanitaire se dégrade
en france peut et est ce qu'ils
imaginaient que le ministre annoncerait
des mesures aussi strictes il s'agit
tout d'abord de la fermeture totale des
bars et des restaurants restaurant fermé
partiellement voire totalement dans
certaines villes de france ces mesures
chocs ont laissé de nombreux français
sans voix mais du côté des people eux
aussi sous le choc certains ont décidé
de faire justement entendre la leur
comme le restaurateur et star de m6
philippe etchebest personne sait rien en
fait
on prend tous dans la gueule comme ça on
le subit ça devient insupportable je
suis désolé elie semoun a quant à lui
réagi à ces mesures en parlant de son
père disparu de rang le confinement le
confinement a tué mon père c'est quasi
criminel d'empêcher nos anciens d'être
entouré de la mort de leurs proches
autre humoriste même constat sauf que de
son côté nicolas bedos appelle carrément
à la désobéissance civile arrêtée tout
où les masques les confinements vivait à
fond tomber malade
allez au restaurant engueuler
flicaillons contredisait vos patrons et
les lâches directives gouvernementales
des réactions à la réception mitigée
alors selon vous les stars ou telle
raison de donner leur avis sur la coved
alors qu'en tout cas il ya un truc sur
lequel je pas d'accord ne conduisaient
patrons soient pas à même si ci a pas de
patron seul patron c'est bernard montiel
parce que c'est le plein d'idées naciri
on aura fait d'eric beigbeder avec nous
dans un instant au téléphone vous vallée
de la hem je suis très étonné vous dites
oui oui elles ont raison de donner leur
avait comme un citoyen comme un citoyen
comme un autre de toute façon il ya une
telle cacophonie qu après tout pourquoi
eux seraient interdites d'ajouter à la
cacophonie
le gouvernement c'est la cacophonie les
dans les régions c'est la cacophonie les
citoyens c'est la cacophonie donc
pourquoi les stars elles n'auraient pas
droit de devenir elle aussi participé à
cette cacophonie ambiante en disant on
n'y comprend rien les uns voulant plus
de fermeté les autres disant au
contraire désobéissance civile après
tout on est dans une république chacun
peut exprimer son point de vue y compris
les stars jean michel maire non moi je
dis non parce qu'on n'y comprend déjà
rien aux scientifiques qui un jour 10
bleus le lendemain rouge que si ma
tantie les acteurs les saint-amand
commencent à donner leurs avis sur la
quelque chose qui est scientifique est
très grave
à laon et on s'est bien passé donc moi
j'avais membres fr ou scientifique en
espérant qu'ils nous qui me balade pas
mais je m'attache à n'importe quoi puis
jean-pierre lui-même lui jean-pierre
dans ce cas je m'en bat marie je suis
d'accord mais
je sais pas ce que je voulais dire
maintenant pardon parce qu on vient vers
toi
le problème c'est qu'on vient vers toi
tout ça il n'y a pas d'avis on a tout ce
qui est dit le lundi 2 mardi le
contraire le mercredi à chaud maintenant
on lit que les mains effectivement les
laver ça protège de plein de choses mais
pas du président
les masques et accor 6 mois fallait pas
les mettre moi j'ai dîné avec un médecin
qui brille est la seule façon de se
protéger est de diminuer le taux
d'infection c'est de porter un masque
qui vont et on est moins contaminés mais
à part ça y est rien je comprends très
bien les lire les acteurs les
restaurateurs parce qu'ils ont pris de
plein fouet un bon pour le spectacle
c'est un drame pour les restaurants
c'est une catastrophe nucléaire et je
comprends qu il ya un peu un symbole
mais ça c'est dit c'est la faute de
murray man qu'il n'a pas été clair dans
ce qu'il fait ce qui gêne si c'était
donner une opinion je suis d'accord mais
là il donne des consignes mais c'est
vrai des consignes de désobéissance
civile risque de mutinerie engueuler les
flics à lyon dans la période actuelle
nicolas bonneau sauf moi je suis choqué
par ce qu'il agrée chanson pour moi dans
ces cas là mieux vaut se taire on peut
donner son opinion
mais aller jusqu à l'incivilité prôné
l'incivilité pour moi c'est dangereux
moneyval bien raison mais là et tu vis
tu parles tu donnes huy dong bang mais
la majeure partie en emmerder renella le
débat c'est sûr ça donc la raison jamais
en dessous des oui oui mais l'acteur
donne le revenu je suis d'accord non non
mais non là on parle de sa wii avec
celle de guy bedos bah oui j'ai vie est
dure et les stars en terre le oui mais
bon c'est surtout parler on parlait sur
sa voix la question porte tu dit non
alors là dessus non là il était fait
trop viola il est obéissant civile il y
en a tellement
un sommet qui font des conneries que
revin et abc rosso serait complètement
fou
si lui cautionner ça moi je suis pas
d'accord voilà bernard et à la gamine
stars donnent leur avis moi je suis
d'accord il ya quand même des mots très
mal choisi et un peu de mépris dire les
fictions c'est pas bien tous à tous qui
tout ce qui dit il a raison sans doute
c'est son choix mais bon on n'insulte
personne il a insulté quand même les
flics les filles qui sont pour rien là
dedans
quant aux mesures gouvernementales ils
vont tous salle aveugle comme tout le
monde dans le monde entier chaque étape
il y découvre des choses nouvelles
ils doivent à chaque fois serait
actualisé et réajuster les mesures
sanitaires c'est compliqué une géraldine
sommes d'accord moi je réveille
je me réveille et je l'aïe que
l'instinct story de nicolas bedos et
puis dix minutes après je vois le tweet
d'un urgentiste en réa qui mollit pas là
vous avez qu'à poser votre libre et
venaient avec montréal et vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir et puis tout
de suite après je lis le tweet de lycées
vous que je retweete parce que je suis
ému et je suis bouleversée je trouve
qu'il a raison
et juste après j'ai mis un tweet de 10
mois mais je me dis bah oui bien sûr
c'est lui qui a raison et c'est pas
lisse exactement qu'en fait on est tous
perdus on ne sait pas et on navigue à
vue
voilà il ya un truc et oui pour qu'ils
donnent leur avis on est d'accord avec
nicolas bedos de turquie par zoug ou de
la douleur parce qu'effectivement sont
eu le sentiment d'être abandonnés bien
je suis enfant parce qu'on ne pouvait
pas le voir
donc ça oui oui quand il dit qu'il faut
ne pas isoler les personnes âgées des
ehpad parce qu'il vaut mieux mourir du
virus que de mourir de chagrin et qui se
sont eux aussi abandonnés et en revanche
n'ont pas à l'appel à lutter conte à
balancer des trucs contre les flics et
pas l'appel à ne pas porter le masque
parce que c'est encore le moindre mal
absolu mon île natale et je voulais
revenir dessus non mais parce que moi je
trouve ça aussi aberrant qu'on ferme les
restaurants je parlais pour les
restaurants là parce que franchement ma
fic est en fac ils sont à 100 dans leur
classe est fermée place pourquoi ils
ferment les restaurants on sait plus où
on va il disent n'importe quoi là dessus
je trouve pas ce qu'il fait il ferme les
restaurants à 22h alors voilà c'est vrai
qu'il ya des voix qui s'élèvent on aura
des restaurateurs dans btp dans un
appentis au bout du rouleau et des
restaurateurs de marseille notamment
il ya frédéric beigbeder écrivain
frédéric qui est un pote de longue date
aussi voilà qu'on apprécie beaucoup
après comme ces codes du monde la
pression des pneus des bap le mois des
trucs sur lesquels ge pas d'accord avec
fédérer y'a des trucs avec les sur
lesquels il n'est pas d'accord avec moi
non mais ça reste quand même quelqu'un
que j'apprécie et frédéric vous vous
avez décidé de quitter paris c'est pour
ça que nous sommes avec vous au
téléphone d'ailleurs tout comme nicolas
bedos vous en avez ras le bol c'est ça
oui non mais je veux dire d'abord je
soutiens à 1000% nicolas je suis très
comment dire heureux qui prennent le
relais puisque moi j'ai dit ça en mai
dernier et vous met tous tombés dessus à
l'époque donc je suis content maintenant
ça va être son tour mais il n'est pas le
premier vous savez le premier à avoir
dit ça c'est molière
donc faisons un débat pour ou contre
molière peut-être mais il a dit dans le
malade imaginaire
presque tous les hommes meurent de leurs
remèdes et non de leur maladie
ouais l'idée là de l'état est très
paternaliste un de vouloir absolument
nous protéger mais en réalité ça va être
des millions de chômeurs en plus et vous
pensez que ça fera pas de victime mais
juste à vapeur aussi beaucoup de morts
un juste très d'eric sur sur la sur la
sur le fond il y en a beaucoup qui sont
d'accord avec nicolas session joue
surtout sur la forme
quand il parle de fille caillons de
rebellions c'est ça qu'on compte ce qui
est reproché plus simple là que le fait
voilà qui disent aux gens c'est vrai
qu'on identifie condamné difficulté
économique incroyable voilà ça on est
tous d'accord avec lui et sur les
mesures qui ont été prises voilà tout le
monde se dit on sait pas trop si c'est
bien aussi c'est pas bien mais si sûr
surtout laon mais il est la forme la rue
et je comprends mais nicolas bedos
il est il il a écrit un texte
pamphlétaire bret donc c'est normal
c'est un style il acquit excessif mais
on est dans une situation où il faut un
peu s'énerver parce qu'il n'y a pas
grand monde dans le camp de la liberté a
en effet tourné quasiment dans une
guerre civile entre d'un côté la santé
et de l'autre la liberté et il ya peu de
voix qui s'élèvent dans le camp de la
liberté
tout le monde a l'air d'accord pour dire
qu'il faut absolument tout interdire
pour sauver des vies alors d'accord mais
pensons aussi à tout ce qu'on est en
train de détruire la culture
c'est vrai que c'est vrai ça c'est
vraiment les discothèques
oui bien sûr mais je n'y pense oui le
plaisir de se retrouver le plaisir
d'être un être humain social et tout ça
qu'on est en train de détruire non je
dis déjà et la dernière fois vous avez
dit pardon jeu j'en profite
vas-y vas-y très directe au contraire
que je disais ça parce que je voulais
boire des mojitos avec mes potes je vois
des caïpirinhas eric frédéric tu sais il
ya plein de trucs sur lesquels on peut
ne pas être d'accord c'est que t'as pas
été d'accord avec moi sur plein de
rigaud 6 mais ça n'empêche pas tus et
apprécie énormément et au contraire
c'est vraiment pour voilà continue
discutent ensemble et que tu vois quand
tu mets exposants qu'on puisse parler
quand tu m'expose ton surya l'acte sur
ce que tu as dit il ya plein de choses
sur lesquelles je suis d'accord avec toi
je te dis franchement si tu as un
message à envoyer paître au gouvernement
tu leur dirais quoi
iraient à attention la réalité c'est que
vous n'avez pas fait votre boulot il n'y
a pas assez d'argent pour les hôpitaux
donc il n'y a pas assez de lits de
réanimation et c'est à cause de ça
aujourd'hui on doit tout arrêter toute
notre vie notre art de vivre
on doit l'arrêter parce qu'il n'y a pas
eu assez d'argent d'or dans la dans les
hôpitaux et les milliardaires qui ont
donné de l'argent pour reconstruire
notre dame
il pourrait peut-être aussi donné des
milliards pour les hôpitaux pour qu'ils
aient enfin d'élus et qu'on puisse vivre